that reminds me was show girls filmed
here
yes of course yeah
what a reference
leading las vegas
very depressing oh goodness okay well
how about some positive news kim
kardashian for those of you who follow
this apparently she has passed the baby
bar logs and there in california so one
step closer to becoming a lawyer it's a
two-step process it was her fourth time
taking the bar we know it's tough um and
she said you know what you just gotta
keep
keep studying you gotta get back up you
gotta do it again and and she did so
good for her she's got one more to go
though all right here we go
wait a minute kim kardashian esquire i
just had to throw this she's going to
start doing that see when i hear that
then i'm going to be thinking of
something totally different
kim kardashian
do you have more movies what do you guys
want to say so
yeah so diamonds are forever oh yeah 3
000 miles to graceland the cooler which
is a good movie by the way and of course
the incredible bert wonderstone oh wait
what happens in vegas with ash and
kutcher
i think that was actually filmed in
toronto oh no i'm just kidding i think
it was filmed here
all right let's get to play the role
we're way off the rails
let's film a weather movie today